we have a new geological era of sorts
called the Anthropocene which more and
more scientists are saying now needs to
be declared according to a number of
different groups including recently one
new expert group that presented their
recommendations at the International
Geological Congress in Cape Town South
Africa the idea is that 1950 would be
the considered the beginning of the
Anthropocene and that it is defined by
radioactive elements dispersed
throughout the planet by nuclear bomb
tests and some other characteristics
including plastic pollution and and and
sort of many many other areas I know you
are very keyed into this entire world
Jason do you have general thoughts about
this before I dig in more to the details
well we in general it is grieved by
scientists that we have been causing
some of the greatest change change as
well as you know extinctions and
endangerment of not only this earth but
of all of its animals including
ourselves really we we might be our own
under the sort of important element of
the Anthropocene is that we are no
longer on the same trajectory as humans
using the planet for whatever it is that
we want to use it for as we've been in
the past so for example compared with
the Holocene of about 12,000 years ago
etc our use of the planet is now having
a different type of impact on our
environment and this is sort of a
different way of approaching the climate
change discussion that we're having
we're sort of assigning a geological
name to what it is that is going on many
geologists are saying that this we now
are at a point where our impact on the
environment is making it so that future
generations are going to have to find
workarounds and some people say the
workaround is we're gonna have to
abandon earth we're going to need some
other place to live others are saying
well the the so-called irreversible
damage that we're doing we're going to
need as yet undiscovered technologies to
figure out
how it can be reversible ideas that
haven't even been thought of that's the
gist of it and it's pretty scary yeah
trying to put a bandaid on this big mess
is just not what needs to be done I know
Fukushima is still still just spouting
radiation the Pacific as we speak you
can see it off of in fish off of the
coast of San Francisco it's no directly
going there three of the waters there's
there's too much needs to be done I
don't know hopefully it's one of these
things we talked about going to Mars
another planet cetera that hopefully our
technology evolves at such a rapid pace
that we can somehow curve this back yeah
the way scientists are seeing it right
now it's it might be too late it's also
horrifying to think that in order to
save the planet we need to get really
good at like going to and living on Mars
like that that that's the extent to
which our technology needs to improve in
order for us to be able to save the
planet
that is pretty horrifying I have to say
yeah I agree and that's maybe our best
hope sadly I want to tell you a terrible
terrible story about incarceration